I'm here to proudly and happily make a
presentation to a man we all love and
admire I have a special reason for
admiring him because I once quite a few
years ago had the pleasure of making a
scene with him we were seated across the
table from each other and he was playing
a fellow who'd had too much to drink and
in the very first take his performance
was so true that I became absolutely
transfixed and completely forgot to pick
up my cue until our director said cut so
we did it again
and I did it again I sadly enthralled
watching the man well we finally of
course got the scene it was in
Philadelphia story and that splendid
actor James Stewart got a well deserved
Academy Award
Jimmy Stewart's decency strength and
kindness is evident in every film he
made
let me read it for you Jimmy I don't
ball fine fine Carrie I'd like to the
Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences honoring award to James Stewart
for his 50 years of memorable
performances for his high ideals both on
and off the screen with the respect and
affection of his colleagues
congratulations
Thank You Kerry and I thank the Board of
Governors of the Academy for this
gracious and most appreciated honor and
I'm also grateful to my fellow actors
and actresses for their help and their
friendship through the years I'm
grateful to producers and writers and
props and grips and makeup and wardrobe
and lighting and cinematographer zalem
well everybody who was there with me and
who helped me to get along so well
between action and cut
I had this the part of this Oscar
belongs to them now good a good part of
it not also especially am i grateful to
Frank Capra
Frank Capra and all of the directors who
have so generously and brilliantly
guided me safely through the no-man's
land of my own good intentions to to
more meaningful performances for which
they share abundant credit in my heart
and finally the audience all you
wonderful folks out there thank thank
you for being so kind to me over the
years you've given me a wonderful life
god bless you